I've always wanted to be an inventor
mainly because I think it would look
great on a business card just inventor
Thomas Edison a pretty good inventor
said that it was 99% perspiration I'm
pretty out of shape I sweat after a
flight of stairs I think I got that part
covered but the 1% inspiration is a
little trickier Leonardo da Vinci now
that dude at ideas like he had the idea
for the helical Air screw which
thankfully we now call the helicopter he
thought of the hand glider and the tank
and tons of other stuff but I know
you're saved and she was pretty good at
drawing you probably have to be pretty
good at drawing to invent things maybe
used to have to be good all the old
patents had amazing drawings but over
time they just turned to crap and yes
that is a reusable bib here's the
drawing that I'm gonna submit for my
invention it's a device that turns off
your cell phone every time you open up
your liquor cabinet I call it the
buzzkill but most of the time when I
have an idea and I search for it
somebody's already thought of it like
the glove compartment refrigerator
already invented same with the automatic
ping pong ball washer how about a
transparent toaster so you can see when
your toast is done there's like five of
them octopus tentacle toilet plunger you
gotta be kidding me
I could always look in old science
fiction books and see what hasn't been
invented yet Jules Verne for example
wrote about tons of stuff that got
invented later on like dirigibles and
electric submarines and a capsule shot
to the moon I mean technically those
ideas are just putting people into tubes
and then imagining the tubes in
different places but you know what else
he thought of a sail that's pushed by a
light which now exists amazing but it's
one thing to imagine going to the moon
and another thing entirely to actually
do it the people at NASA did invent
thousands of things to make that happen
a lot of which you've probably used like
insoles for your sneakers or charcoal
water filters or cordless tools because
it turns out there aren't that many
outlets on the moon and I think those
kind of inventions are my favorite kind
that was born out of need or necessity
like the tin can invented so that
soldiers could eat non rotten food
although in that case the can opener
wasn't invented for another thirty years
oops or like when Joseph Friedman was at
a fountain parlor with his daughter and
she was having trouble drinking out of a
straw so he invented the flexible straw
inventions inspired by a need don't need
to be that fancy there's still a lot of
people that need a lot of things like
ease are Gough knees $9 cardboard
a sickle that can hold up to 450 pounds
or like onder's Wilhelmsen spew bag
which allows human waste to be composted
in a way that doesn't contaminate
groundwater simple amazing inventions
and that's what I love about inventors
to keep looking everywhere
although Neil Armstrong didn't invent
much I think he summed up inventors when
he said I think we're going to the moon
because it's in the nature of the human
being to face challenges it's by the
nature of his deep inner soul were
required to do these things just as
salmon swim upstream
what will you invent happy inventors day
[Music]